we have a wonderful prop master here on
our show we featured him over the years
he handles all the props here on the
show and organizes him takes care of him
his name is Bill tall yeah we've done
for a couple of years we've done
something on our show called bill tolls
tips and it's become so popular that
Honda approached us said they'd like to
sponsor a built all online show this is
real this really happened so let's bring
them out right now bill tell everybody
so Billy I'm excited about your new
webseries I'm over the moon okay great
now Bill's shot three episodes and we'd
like to premiere the first one here on
our show so please enjoy bill towles
prop master challenge brought to you by
Honda boom prop master challenge you got
it
we need a puppy a violin in a bathtub
yes mr. tall
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now you said the pose for the show just
keep playing
that's a minuet I wanted a wall
[Music]
[Applause]
no one radiates joy like built all to
see all three of bills episodes go to
Team Coco comm slash prop master bill
tell everybody there's no one better
you